the breaking news that's come out of
parliament today in the last few minutes
the defense secretary Ben Wallace has
been speaking in the comments about
Ukraine and an incident involving an RAF
aircraft and Russian fighter jet so
here's what he said
remember an unarmed RAF
rc-135 rivet joint a civilian I start
aircraft on routine Patrol over the
Black Sea was interacted with by two
Russian armed su-27 fighter aircraft
it is not unusual for aircraft to be
shadowed and this day was no different
during that interaction however it
transpired that one of the su-27
aircraft
released a missile in the vicinity of
the RAF rivet joint Beyond visual range
the total time of the interaction
between the Russian aircraft and the
rivet joint was approximately 90 minutes
the patrol completed and the aircraft
returned to its base
in light of this potentially dangerous
engagement I've communicated my concerns
directly to my Russian counterpart
defense minister shoigu and the chief of
Defense staff in Moscow and and has done
so my colleague the chief defense staff
has also communicated his concerns in my
left
well it's got some reaction now from our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes he's in The Newsroom for us so
Deborah what should we make of this
incident then it's very serious um
you've excuse my voice I've lost it a
little bit but um it just shows that
while the the defense secretary he's
still speaking in Parliament at the
moment
um he says that he doesn't the UK
doesn't consider this to be a deliberate
escalation by the Russians and that
um the analysis
um suggests that this was more of a
malfunction it does underline the risks
that you have of a mistaken escalation a
mistaken incident when you have a lot of
military aircraft military operations
taking place around Ukraine of course
the UK is not directly involved in the
war in Ukraine it's got in terms of
troops on the ground and aircraft and
jets involved directly in the conflict
um the UK like other Western allies has
been supplying the Ukrainian Armed
Forces is with um with weapons for them
to fight but at the same time you have a
lot of Russian aircraft that are
directly engaged in this war
um clearly they are using the airspace
around Ukraine Ukraine is part of Europe
and therefore you also have quite
legitimately UK and other NATO aircraft
and jets operating in the Black Sea area
around the the area the baltics around
this whole War Zone in Ukraine not
directly in Ukraine but if you have the
the two sides operating in that area
then the potential for some kind of
mistake obviously Rises and that seems
to be what the defense secretary is
suggesting happened on the 29th of
September he said that
um the these two Russian fighter jets
were sort of shadowing the um the
British spy plane as it was conducting
this routine Patrol and it took the
whole interaction that is normal you
often have when Russian Jets come close
to buzzing UK airspace the UK will
scramble Jets to um to accompany them
but it seems during this the course of
this interaction which lasts about it
lasted about an hour and a half a
missile was released by one of the
Russian jets in the vicinity of the UK
warplane
um if it was it was a theme so it was a
malfunction but it does show that it
could have been something much worse and
and clearly it's a serious incident and
that's why the defense secretary is
talking about it at this time of
political chaos
Deborah thanks very much indeed for that
very Swift analysis thank you